hey guys I'm Brian right hey guys a
major Andrew now with a YouTube channel
movie source check it out
talks about movies obviously today we're
gonna talk about Empire Strikes Back or
is it the Empire the Empire straight and
like the Empire Strikes Back this film
whoa we just talked about a new hope or
Star Wars what everyone called and that
film incredible this film tops it one of
those rare sequels where you're like not
only did they get a budget but they use
their budget to an advantage to give it
a just some basic stuff right upfront a
more solid cinematography better makeup
and costumes they were able to get like
better choreography for the lightsaber
fight just everything about it was was
there on a technical level better now
budget and production does not
necessarily equate to a better movie
Hobbit prequels of the film does a
better job storytelling - wow that was
that is one of the most anticipated
sequels of all time and Wow yeah and
growing up as a kid when I first saw
this film I thought it was good for sure
but it was definitely the least favorite
of mine of the trilogy after we watching
it several several several times it's
not even close not only is it the best
Star Wars film ever it's one of the best
movies ever made advert it's definitely
in my top 10 what I loved also about
this film just on top of everything you
said they took us to so many places that
we never thought we were gonna go not
only did it go darker and deeper but we
learned more about the force we learn
more about Luke we learn more about all
the characters that we love we learn
more about what motivates them into
going to the neck without just whatever
just again more character arcs this
movie is just amazing it's phenomenal I
can't wait to get onto it the first one
teases the Jedi world you know like you
get obi-wan Kenobi yeah and that's about
as far as it goes and the fourth and you
get the force so it's more about the
force than it is about the Jedi right
this one you really get a sense of the
Jedi world and what used to be there you
know Yoda
[ __ ] love
Eureka's amazing dude when I watch Yoda
it's like it's weird because I'm like he
has a creepy look up front but I wanna
own one you know like I want a little
Yoda one yeah I like his introduction of
this guy who's just on this forsaken
planet though he's a Jedi Master and
he's on the planet Dagobah
Dagobah you know and that isn't I just
when mate when he's landing on that
planet the visuals we see a both a
branch isn't Turan landing in that swamp
I mean that place is disgusting it's
nasty it's a nasty world and this is
where like the master Jedi is [ __ ]
chillin yeah and I gotta tell you to
that whole thing could have really not
worked that puppet I mean how they made
it work how they made it talk and
interact with Luke it just really could
have fallen apart very easily if you
really think about it's not see they
didn't have CGI back in those days it's
a puppet the guys who did the
puppeteering and again Frank Oz the
voice brilliant masterful job like you
truly really feel this guy is a Jedi
Master and use a matter it doesn't
matter his size like you just in each
scene that we dug deep when he's using
his mind using the force you really feel
that this is really one of the greatest
Jedi warriors of all time it's it's cool
because the Jedi's are like samurais
Yoda kind of reminds me of like a kung
fu teacher actually I know it's not the
same good kung fu teacher one who has
like a sense of humor it kind of makes
fun of the student yeah but he's really
always trying to teach in something even
when he's clowning on him he's trying to
get an emotion out of him to teach him
something about how he responds that
scene when Luke is like the ship's too
[ __ ] big can't [ __ ] do it
[ __ ] you Yoda and then Yoda is like and
he just levitate that ship out of the
water and in the line that ends he is
like I don't believe in him he goes back
exactly perfect perfect line such
classic philosophical dialogue I know
the dialogue isn't there's so much
better in this movie and I know they
added Laurence Katzen to do the
screenwriting with George Lucas you can
clearly tell it ups the game and they
added someone as I'm George Lucas did
this story it outlined it but there was
Lawrence Katzen and someone put the
director this film was urban Kirchner he
did Robocop - it's the only other film I
know he did good yeah all right this is
a good sequel if you did not robocop -
so um but no biggie there was different
director George still did the story I
believe like you said and then they had
Lawrence Kasdan who is writing episode 7
and he's also writing episode 8 and the
Han Solo anthology film
yeah Leigh Brackett also co-wrote this
script and she died about a year before
George Lucas finished outlining it but
she was the one who came up with the
twist actually Darth Vader being Luke
Skywalker's father and at first George
Lucas didn't like it
she passed away and George Lucas decided
to go with it and damn does that all
that that just changes the whole thing
in a brilliant way and yet you're like
it makes sense you know
absolutely it's definitely a twist you
never see coming when that reveal like
you said it makes sense and also on top
of that a fun fact they didn't tell any
of the actors about that because they
didn't want them spoiling anything or
you know they told James Earl Jones the
day of filming and they also told Mark
Hamill both of them could not put like
they didn't know if they were that the
screenwriter and director were lying to
them they had to like confirm that with
them so that's a little fun fact they
weren't they had no idea either they
found out the day of they were related
so I think that's smart cuz you can see
him in Mark Hamill's reaction yeah he
did not know about the part is Hamels
Act that's what I mean even the acting
improv this time around everyone brought
it down a little bit they weren't as
over-the-top Mark Hamill especially
impressed me much more sincere much more
subtle more toned down he's not like
over-the-top personality in this one so
he's also more wide he's more wise and
it's a really cool journey of a Jedi
Knight you know like a man who doesn't
realize he's a Jedi Knight he has a
bigger purpose in life he thought it was
just to join the rebellion and become a
pilot now he's like wait there's more
for me you know so that moment when Luke
freaks out over finding out that's that
denial he goes into that like just can't
be real powerful oh my goodness powerful
that could have been so cheesy and
over-the-top and he just delivered it
perfectly absolutely the villains the
enemy and it's such a powerful moment
dear and the way he reacts you can feel
it and I could only imagine how everyone
in the theater was like
I really wish I could have seen that
back in the day in theaters one last
thing about Darth Vader every scene in
this film where they're showing him when
someone fails him and he starts choking
I mean it just shows how he how powerful
and evil a villain is and how desperate
he is to get Luke Skywalker yeah like
you [ __ ] this up you're in the way of me
completing my name and you can tell -
like I mean near the end - and when the
Millennium Falcon escapes and you see
Admiral Piett space yeah when when Darth
Vader turns around you can tell he's
like oh I'm gonna get force-choked but
you know Darth Vader didn't because in
my opinion he was very--it he was too
angry over the situation he just said
[ __ ] it whatever okay first off uh Vader
they even improved his suit I noticed it
wasn't as thick you know there was more
slim fitting for the guy Vader you get
more of his personality in this film you
do he's more than just like you see that
he's becoming obsessed you see that he
even has someone above him the Emperor
you know you don't see the emperor in
the first one no we don't see the
Emperor at all we just hear mention only
Grand Moff Tarkin just taught when they
go to a to a table scene and in the New
Hope where they talk about the Senate
dissolving or something starts choking
the gun yeah exactly they just they just
say that the they just made contact with
the Emperor and he dissolved the Senate
or something like that but still like
that's just one little brief moment was
awesome and your letter the impression
of Darth Vader's the leader of all this
when you see that Oh Darth Vader's
answering to someone there was a
interesting exchange of dialogue knowing
the twist and then watching the film is
interesting exchange the dialogue saying
he is the son of Anakin Skywalker and
how Darth Vader has just totally
separated himself from whom Anakin
Skywalker is that he can't even remember
at first and now to see him answering
someone's like wow okay interest and
it's just a great great scene that just
that two-minute moment right there just
tells you everything you need to know
about why Darth bit about who Darth
Vader answers to and why he does what he
does and the tease is to like that one
shot you get of just the back of Darth
Vader's bald head with this song and he
sounds like he's too bald like something
happened to him you know you could tell
there was an accident that happened but
they don't might go into detail about
what happened
showing stuff off and visual as opposed
to having to go ex visit the exposition
around and explaining every single thing
just showing us that image
the back of his head you can you could
tell something bad happened to this guy
an element in ads it's intense it's an
intense movie dude like it is a non-stop
adventure this one all the battles the
Battle of Hoth the Cloud City yeah the
the asteroid field I mean there's some
amazing scene it has it goes from the
Battle of Hoth and then it goes into the
Millennium Falcon chase which turns into
the asteroid field love that scene and
then there's luke's adventure that's
going on and then he's learning from
Yoda on how to be a Jedi it's fun as
they keep like the other characters more
of a fun plot you know like it's not as
serious and heavy because the dynamics
of them are all kind of fun like they
infuse the romance with Han and Leia
which works totally works it's not
forced it's not jump down our throat you
can see that relationship really develop
she cannot stand him at first but deep
down she really has a love for him yeah
and I mean you just you see it build up
it's again it's not forced and told to
us it is should we see it happen and we
believe it you really can you really
believe that they're in love that moment
where he gets frozen that classic title
argue exchange I love you I know yeah
fun fact the line was I love you in Han
Solo's line was I love you too Harrison
Ford told the director and the
screenwriter on set that day Han Solo
would never say I love you too so he
improvised the line I know
Harrison Ford you're the man yeah oh god
I didn't know that yep whoa nailed it on
set improvised it what's it what's so
unique about this film so unique and the
only other sequel that I've seen that
does that's done it recently is the Dark
Knight was they end on a note where
you're like we need a sequel but that's
what makes it unique it's not like we
need a sequel because I didn't finish
telling the [ __ ] story in this one
and they're clearly dragging this out
they told the complete chapter a
complete story that makes you go we need
more we need to see what happens next
you know that's the one thing I'm happy
about that I didn't have to endure in
the theer's know if the way three years
yeah you know when I I got this when I
got to see it I'll just pop in the next
DVD perfect or actually I saw them in
theaters so I only had to wait like a
month when they did the re-release yeah
1997 so that was the first time
I had my experience in theaters with
these films and just so blown away it
was amazing it goes back to like okay
like the original trilogy Lord of the
Rings each film yes you there's more to
the story after the end of like the
first two but each one still feels like
a complete movie as a composed to the
prequels which are like this is one
dragged out film and the Hobbit - I mean
yeah yeah like you're sorry the prequels
to the ha - Lord the Rings and the
prequels - stars it's really the same
thing you know you got epic amazing told
stories in in the first Lord of the
Rings trilogy in Star Wars trilogy and
then an over-reliance on CGI in and
budget in The Hobbit and the prequels
and we're not here to bag on those films
but just you can just completely tell
the differences in trilogies you know
from with the originals to the prequels
the last thing I would say is the the
the fight between Vader and Luke all is
to this day it's not the most insanely
choreo
yeah cuz I've talked it what's for that
time great yeah look the Star Wars
prequel fights are their bed they're
better but I would say this the the
fights in the original trilogy they're
more emotionally impacting we care for
these characters true in the frequent
care about Anakin I had someone care
about obi-wan I guess cuz you and did a
good job but I don't care about Darth
Maul he's a cool character but it's it's
meaningless fights oh they're fighting
some random guy who I've seen in three
scenes cool yeah and this movie like oh
man this is this is no reason emotional
impact characters you you are seeing our
hero and our villain go toe-to-toe face
to face they didn't do that in the first
one you know like yeah there's a little
fight they were having in the ships but
now we're seeing like Vader has been
hunting Luke and Luke has been preparing
to take down Vader
and here's their moment and I love at
the beginning the five theaters just
taunting him he could take him down in
two seconds if he really wanted to he's
just talking and taunting him it's just
such a joke about if you wanted to you
know yeah so but and then you see that
whole part where Luke jumps out of the
Carbonite grabs the the lightsaber by
the floor just such a powerful scene and
I love how they change from look even
though they're it's still in the same
location
from room to room the gym scene the
scene it's not like oh there's a blue
screen and a bunch of stuff behind those
tension-filled
fight it's it's not about the
choreography it's it's more like the
choreography actually it's about it
because there's storytelling in the
courtyard absolutely like Darth Vader's
not saying a bunch of dialogue taunting
Luke like he's taunting him and then you
see he's like kind of letting Luke have
a few hits yeah and then when Luke
starts getting a few hits art fairs like
oh you have my game up a little bit you
know and then eventually he's like [ __ ]
this guy I'm started using the force on
him they start thrashing Luke yeah puts
a bunch of objects a point and he just
cuts off his arm yeah amazing movie what
do you want to read it I want to rate it
5 hand solo jobs what he said yeah John
seriousness no this this movie if there
was a score 5 out of 5 10 out of 10
whatever this movie is flawless it's
epic there's honestly not very many
things I can think of that that bothered
me about that honestly there's really
not many at all of anything I'd say
maybe Lando wearing Hans clothes at the
end was weird other than that there's
nothing that really bothers me Billy Dee
Williams Harvey Dent and Batman man yeah
anyway guys listen thanks for tuning in
to the channel if you're new to it click
this button add a subscribe become a
reject Andrew now has a channel there's
a lot of movie talks on there check it
out movie source link in the description
box go there now follow us on our social
networks and you're mainly tweets I
Instagram some people don't realize that
shoot videos in advance oh oh that's how
you do that huh some people think like
any video I shoot I must put it up bad
oh yeah no no I want to use that [ __ ]
none of us have lives we do this every
day man